millions of people along the northern
Gulf Coast are in the path of a
dangerous storm subtropical storm
Alberto is expected to make landfall
this afternoon four days before the
official start of hurricane season
Mississippi Alabama and Florida are
currently under a state of emergency
Manuel Bojorquez is in Panama City
Florida which is preparing for Alberto's
arrival Manuel good morning good morning
Hurricane Hunters have measured wind
speeds up to 65 miles per hour near the
center of the storm and hours before it
makes landfall here in Panama City Beach
you can already see just how dangerous
the surf has become and we're getting
band after band of rain already some
residents of Three Counties have had to
evacuate and for millions of people who
live here along the Gulf Coast it is a
reminder that despite what the calendar
says hurricane season has begun intense
winds and heavy rainfall battered the
northern Gulf Coast on Sunday a preview
of Alberto's impact was seen in Cuba
where the island experienced four inches
of rain in less than eight hours
the storms outer bands stretched across
Florida dumping heavy rain as far east
as Miami we're walking into hurricane
season everybody needs to get prepared
typically packed beaches were largely
empty with red flags warning swimmers of
dangerous rip currents and high surf
people are not allowed to go in the
water there could be legal consequences
if they go in the water because they're
very dangerous
residents along the Gulf Coast lined
their homes and businesses with sandbags
a practice that has become all too
familiar I'm concerned and I'm listening
and that's all I can do take it one step
at a time
Alberto has also dealt a blow to
businesses over the holiday weekend it's
usually crazy busy down here the people
are staying at home and watching it
themselves and to vacationers like Karen
Burnett who traveled from Texas with two
children and I've never seen the beach
we wanted them to have this experience
it's going to be cut short very Alberto
is expected to make landfall this
afternoon and then weakened to a
subtropical depression as it moves north
last week forecasters predicted a 35%
chance of an above average hurricane
season so a storm so early like this has
many people wondering what may be in
store
Vlad Manuel Bojorquez thank you very
much